so um
here's what happened
harry rose was on wip yesterday and he
admitted
that tom donahoe former gm at the
steelers and the bills he wanted
to stay put
at i believe it was 70 and take north
carolina state defensive tackle alan
mcneil right right the eagles traded
back three spots to pick up a sixth
rounder
and mcneil was taken one spot earlier by
the lions right so the eagles were
relegated to defensive tackle milton
williams
donahoe
wanted mcneal and donahoe thought it was
a waste of time basically to pick up the
extra sixth-round pick that was jeff
mclean's report from the philadelphia
enquirer so that that's the backstory
that's why the half-hearted fist bump
and
tom donahoe's like oh yeah yeah and why
was it huh what huh what
so that's what happened and i like the
transparency of course what what can you
do it was caught on camera you can't act
like we were having a dispute about
whether it was diet pepsi or regular
pepsi in the back of the room obviously
it was about whatever happened with that
pick so of course how he had no choice
but to be transparent explain what
happened chris yeah i mean
when there's nothing wrong with that to
just be transparent and it's okay i mean
do we really think that it's just like
every pick there's gonna be ten men in a
room and are all going to just be like
yes that was the best pick we ever had
of course not there's going to be guys
who are going to go no i think this guy
would have been better blah blah blah
it's part of you know working in a front
office and if you have a healthy front
office you hopefully you do have a few
guys that you know will say no i don't
like this or challenge you on your
thoughts a little bit and everything
like that um i i will say to defend tom
donahoe i i agree with them they missed
out i think on a significantly better
player to lee mcneil who i thought was
like one of the more special d tackles
in the draft and i'm sure detroit was
doing cartwheels to get him because
again he's a an ass kicker who dominates
the line of scrimmage and bites kneecaps
off and that's all detroit drafted in
the draft so he's a perfect fit for that
so i get that um i did get a chuckle a
little bit out of tom donahoe's comments
on the whole thing uh him trying to put
the toothpaste back in the toothpaste
holder was pretty funny too
well
and you know what's amazing to me is
that donahoe was mortified by this it
just shows you he is the classic old
school football guy yeah right because
actually it reminded everyone that tom
donahoe is still in the nfl i'd say 99
of football fans just assumed that he
wasn't
he got some free publicity and his
explanation to chris mortensen of espn
does not ring true to most i
he's flabbergasted that it went viral
and he says that's silly i didn't even
know i was on camera well that that we
know that's why it was so real
yes
reality tv is only real if you don't
know that you're on camera right when
you know you're on camera you behave
differently he wouldn't have been so
half-hearted he wouldn't have directed
a commented howie roseman that caused
howard to go
what's your deal essentially so the fact
that he didn't know it was on camera
proves it was a very real moment and
that he was frustrated and he let it out
and he wouldn't have let it out if he
had known he was on camera right so it's
okay it is okay exactly
right run with it yeah
and it would be a shame
if he ends up getting whacked over this
uh but uh you know obviously he's got to
be concerned there's going to be some
sort of ramification because in that
moment where he didn't realize that the
cameras are everywhere and tom and
anyone else out there who's in a draft
room or anywhere else really just assume
a camera's everywhere
that's what happens yeah and that that
real moment comes out yeah well
hopefully nobody's gonna judge him too
critically there in the eagles
organization i mean howie it's not the
first time i'm sure he's had somebody in
that room disagree with the pick or
anything like that so i hope it doesn't
go that way i do think though
you're right
he was probably mortified by the whole
thing too you know it's old school
personnel guy
and you know especially the old school
let's hey we we follow leadership it's
file and rank and i'm behind this guy
and whatever he says yes the sky's red
okay the sky's red it's not blue he he
said it's red that's that's the way
front office works so i'm sure he was
embarrassed that way that he kind of
looked like you know revolutionary and
in a degree that way but uh yeah it's
all right and like you said just own it
and move on the last thing those old
school guys want is to have their name
in the paper and they resent anyone yeah
who comes off as trying to seek
publicity that's why i think he was even
more
mortified he came off as that guy that
he's hated his entire career the guy
who's trying to get his name in the
spotlight usurp authority and and be a
show-off be a fancy man that's what my
dad just said trying to be a fancy dan
there get some attention oh fancy dan i
like it
yeah that was the thing back in the 70s
i never knew what it meant but i knew
that that's that's you know you got to
be very reserved you got to be very
under the radar you got to go about your
business and don't go out and seek that
extra attention so that was uh i think
another reason why donahoe was trying to
put the toothpaste back in the
toothpaste holder here's how he roseman
not trying to put the toothpaste back in
the toothpaste holder as it relates to
the move up from 12 to 10 to get in
front of the giants
to get devonta smith the guy that many
thought the giants would have taken
here's how he talking about that
when all these investigative stories had
come out saying that howie roseman has
his own draft board and howie roseman
sometimes follows howie roseman or jeff
lurie's instincts instead of those of
the coach or or the or the coaches or
the scouts
did less of that happen this year can
you shed a little light on that for us
angela that's ridiculous every single
person on our staff has their own draft
board that's how we write up reports so
everyone in their system nick has his
own draft board andy weidel has their
own draft bar tom donahoe has their own
draft board i have my own draft board
that's how we rank players that's how
our system is set up to do that we have
an eagles draft board that reflects a
lot of things and my job is to bring
them all together i listen to everyone
to try to make these decisions and at
the same time
someone may be unhappy because it may
not be reflected accurately in all the
information that i have that they may
not have and so i think that's the job
of everyone in my position around the
league and that's what's happening
around the league you know i speak to a
lot of gm's i've been doing this for a
long time this is this isn't unique to
the philadelphia eagles all right howie
was there unanimous agreement on devonta
smith
yes
i just wanted to be sure yeah he's
always a naysayer you know howie once in
a while a guy wants to go into the grain
everybody loved devonte cross the board
everyone loves devonte smith
angelo cataldi in the wip morning team i
don't know that howie's going to hold up
very well under questioning i wasn't
very convinced by the responses there
we're trying to get howie on the program
we can talk to him a little bit more
about that but are you ever going to
have unanimous opinion when you do
something like that when you give up
assets to move up two spots to get a guy
that you think your division rival is
going to take a guy who's 166 pounds
i would assume that someone
in that group there's too many people
to have them all be unanimous that that
was the right move chris and all that
matters is what jeffrey lurie ultimately
wants because we learned one thing this
year he's a
amateur mel keiper and he gets involved
in the process and he puts his board
together and if that's what the boss
wants that's what the boss gets well
yeah all that matters is the top
decision makers and of course roseman
lurie you know maybe a few other guys
that have got high positions within the
organization they're gonna definitely
listen to them their opinions are going
to hold a little bit more weight yeah
would i think everybody in that room was
totally like as just you know 100
percent happy devonta smith was their
guy or whatever probably not to your
point no but again devante smith it was
every bit worthy of that pick and when
the only negative thing you can do say
about the guy is 166. and i and i will
say too
you know again at pick 10 i i know
there's other teams out there that had
devonte smith as their number one
receiver as one of the better receivers
they've evaluated the last few years
coming out in the draft so there are
teams that looked at him and probably
scratched their head and like really the
dolphins like waddle more than him
because i think there was a number of
teams that looked at him and going no
he's special he's the guy that should be
picked number one at receiver obviously
howie felt that way and we know there's
some other teams out there that did too
and the benefit for devonta smith
because he was the third receiver take
and he'll have a little extra fuel to
the fire he'll have an extra incentive
to prove
the bengals wrong at five and the
dolphins wrong especially the dolphins
wrong at six for taking his teammate
right before they took the guy who was
wrecking the ohio state buckeyes in the
first half of the national championship
game until he had that fluke finger
injury that caused him to exit the rest
of the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports